pour la vidéo j'ai peut-être l'enlever
quand même 1 3 5 7 9
comment complète auriez-vous cette suite
probablement par use
non ça a l'air d'être la suite des
nombres impairs qu'en est il de la suite
2 3 5 7 11 2 3 5 7 11
ça a l'air d'être la suite des nombres
premiers noms auquel cas le suivant
serait 13 quid de m coeur barre en
dessous 8 ce symbole bizarre et sept
autres symboles bizarre là c'est plus
difficile
d'ailleurs je vais vous l'essayez
réfléchir quid de cette suite 1 2 4 8 16
si vous deviez compléter cette suite
comment la complète heures et vous et
puis à quel point êtes-vous sûr de vous
[Musique]
prenez un gâteau en forme de disque je
vais maintenant m'être un point sur le
bord du disque et d'un le gâteau est un
morceau
jusque là rien de très surprenant
maintenant je vais mettre un deuxième
point sur le bord du disque et je vais
donner un coup de couteau entre les deux
points du bord du 10
maintenant le gâteau et en deux morceaux
mettons maintenant un troisième point
sur le bord du disque et je coupe encore
une fois le gâteau le long des droites
qu'il joigne ce nouveau point pour point
précédent désormais le gâteau étant un
deux trois quatre morceaux
si je prends un quatrième point et si je
coupe le gâteau encore une fois en
joignant ce 4e point au pont précédent
je commence à avoir un gâteau qui ne
ressemble plus à grand chose mais on
peut prouver ses morceaux il y en a 1 2
3 4 5 6 7 8 et donc la suite des nombres
de parts de gâteau jusque là ça fait 1
de 4,8
d'après vous quel est le nombre de parts
que j'obtiendrais avec un cinquième
point
eh bien on peut ajouter ce 5ème points
et donné quatre coups de couteau qu'il
rejoigne au point précédent et on
obtient ainsi 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 9 10 11 12
13 14 15 16 morceaux et là il est quand
même super tentant de dire que le
sixième nombre de la suite sera celui
qu'on n'obtiendra si on ajoute un
sixième point et cinq coups de couteau
et là on obtient 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 9 10 11
12 13 14 15 16 17 18 19 20 21 22 23 24
26 27 28 29 30 et 31
morceaux aux biens 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 9 10
11 12 13 14 15 16 17 18 19 20 21 22 23
24 25 26 27 28 29 30 et
ça fait bien trente et un ipad 32
étrangement oui parce que vous avez
probablement une impression que la suite
1 2 4 8 16 était la suite d'épisodes de
2 ou pour passer d'un nombre au suivant
multiplié par deux et si c'était le cas
l'élément suivant de la suite devrait
alors être 32 et non pas 31 mai alors
qu'elle est la bonne façon de compléter
la suite faute il a complété par 31 ou
par 32 ou peut-être par autre chose
encore à moins que ce genre d'exercice
si courant dans les tests de qi
mais en fait aucun sens quelle forme
d'intelligence est vraiment mise en
oeuvre dans les tests de qi est il
rationnel de chercher à compléter une
suite
peut-on vraiment utiliser le
raisonnement pour deviner le prochain
nombre d' une suite de nombres
l'un des premiers à se rendre compte de
la difficulté de ces questions et le
grand philosophe écossais david qm en
1748 dans son formidable essai sur
l'entendement humain qu on me fit la
remarque importante que la logique ne
permet pas de compléter de tels suite et
ce ne sont pas les logiciens moderne qui
le contrediront la logique consiste à
partir de fondement appelé axiom est de
règle dite de déductions pour ensuite
calculer les conséquences des actions et
des règles de déduction
sauf que le problème de la confession
des suites n'est absolument pas un
problème axiomatique en fait on ne
connaît même pas les règles qu'il faut
suivre ne sont écrites nulle part en
tout cas pas dans la suite
puis il fit remarquer qu'on avait là un
problème différent de nature un problème
beaucoup moins bien défini mais aussi et
surtout un problème beaucoup plus
important et pertinent
en pratique bien souvent en pratique si
ce n'est en fait quasiment toujours il
faut regarder des données ou un exemple
et à partir de ces observations
il nous faut ensuite deviner les règles
qui régissent ces données pour ensuite
faire des prédictions sur le futur
suprême qui consiste à partir des
observations pour un ferrer des règles
c'est ce que fut m'appelait le problème
de l'induction
et ça c'est très certainement le
problème le plus important des sciences
oui imaginez qu'au lieu de la suite 1 2
4 8 16
on considère une suite d'observations
empiriques par exemple les nombre de
nouveaux cas confirmés de kobe des dix
neuf semaines après semaines
faut-il alors cherché à compléter cette
suite
il rationnel de le faire ou du moins y
at il des raisonnements correct pour
compléter la suite
tel un excellent mathématicien fuel eu
l'idée géniale de simplifier au maximum
le problème de l'induction en prenant
l'exemple du lever de soleil chaque jour
le soleil se lève ou plutôt jusque là
chaque jour on a observé le soleil se
lever mais ces observations passées
suffit-elle à prédire que le soleil se
lèvera demain
imaginons un observateur à lausanne qui
tous les jours à midi
note 1 dans son carnet si le soleil
s'est levé et 06 le jour ne s'est pas
levé son carnet ne contiendrait pour
l'instant que des 1
il aura une suite qui s'est créée un an
et ainsi de suite jusqu'à 1 10 millièmes
ainsi son âge approche de la trentaine
nous encore s'il s'appuie sur des
théories scientifiques il pourrait même
imaginer que la suite de 10000 1 et d'en
faire précéder d'une suite de 1000
milliards 2,1 milliards 2,1 à la suite
est-ce que ça vous donne envie de
compléter cette suite par un autre par
hasard on dit souvent qu'il ne faut pas
faire de généralités mais là quand même
non peut-être quand même ici généraliser
cette suite 2-1 et prédire que le
prochain élément de la suite est aussi à
un nom enfin si vous deviez paris
qu'est-ce que vous pariez
est-ce que vous pariez que le soleil va
se lever demain vous ce que vous pariez
contre cela mais surtout quel
raisonnement
utilisez-vous pour compléter cette suite
2-1 quel algorithmes utilisés vous pour
compléter cette suite et surtout cet
algorithme correspond-t-il un
raisonnement valide selon view non votre
raisonnement n'est pas valide
en fait selon pew aucun raisonnement
valides ne permet de conclure que le
prochain élément de cette suite est à 1
alors vous pourrez quand même rétorqué
que vous avez l'habitude de parier sur
le lever du soleil ou au moins sur
d'autres choses et que votre méthode
pour parier a fait ses preuves
autrement dit vous pourriez dire qu'à
chaque fois que vous avez utilisé votre
algorithmes de généralisation au moins
dans les cas où il ya mille milliards de
données concordantes
vous avez fait la bonne prédiction et du
coup votre méthode paraît va
id mais en fait ceci revient à dire que
si vous teniez un carnet de notes avec
vos prédictions
si vous mettiez un à chaque fois que
votre algorithmes prédictifs voix juste
et zéro sinon alors vous auriez dans
votre carnet de notes uniquement des uns
peut être des milliers de 1 si vous
pariez très régulièrement
mais cela suffit-il à dire que votre
algorithmes d'induction le bon
algorithme et que sa prochaine
prédictions sera elle aussi juste est il
possible de généraliser le succès d'un
algorithme de généralisation htm et
admettant ce problème aussi a été
identifié par young et il l'a qualifié
de problème de meta induction et ce
problème de la métare adduction a de
quoi donner le tournis
il semble aussi et surtout montré que au
bout d'un moment il va nous falloir
poser des bases à l'induction est
accepté au moins certains principes pour
s'accorder plus ou moins sur le degré de
validité d'un algorithme d'induction est
justement probablement grâce à
l'influencé d'un géologistes appelé
james righton qm introduisit un principe
qui se considère à incontournable pour
justifier la généralise à billy t d'une
enduction ce principe est appelé le
principe d'uniformes et charisme de la
nature qu'on appelle aussi parfois le
principe de régularité et qui postule
une similarité entre le passé le présent
et le futur
une persistance de certaines lois de la
nature
en vertu d'une telle uniformité du monde
il semble alors justifiable de penser
qu'il est possible
disons acceptable de généraliser en
partie le passé au passage d' influence
de la géologie sur qm me fait dire que
la géologie n'est pas une science c'est
bien plus que ça c'est une vocation
c'est une philosophie c'est une
grammaire c'est un cap c'est une
péninsule c'est une fille dit
félicitations nous l'appellerons mehdi
lui plus sérieusement le cas de redonne
mais aussi d'autres géologistes comme
charrs laguiole qui a inspiré darwin ou
à old boys qui s'est opposé à fischer
tout ça me fait dire que peut-être grâce
aux particularités de leur discipline
les géologues ont souvent eu une erreur
géologique d' avance sur l'épistémologie
de leurs contemporains des autres
sciences et ce n'est peut-être pas un
hasard si le mot calcul signifie calme
en la dent en fait si c'est sans doute
un accident plutôt qu'autre chose mais
bref revenons à nokia tune donc suggérer
ainsi l'existence de lois de la nature
qui sont invariante à travers le temps
ok soit mais ça ne nous avance pas tant
que ça quelles sont ces lois de la
nature et surtout comment les déterminer
avant de répondre directement à cette
question il est peut être utile de
d'abord envisagé tous les candidats
possibles à être des lois de la nature
quelles sont les choses qui pourra
correspondre à des lois et bien
historiquement les lois en général
correspondent à des instructions à
suivre pour déterminer le jugement des
citoyens d'un pays
et oui cette formalisation des lois et
ce qui permettait de garantir autant que
possible le principe d'égalité
procédurales c'est à dire le fait que la
loi s'applique de la même manière pour
tous indépendamment des biais implicite
ou explicite des jugements or les
instructions à suivre
c'est ce qu'on pourra aussi appelé des
méthodes des recettes et procédures ou
encore dans les langages informatiques
des algorithmes
d'ailleurs le mot algorithmes n'est
autre que le nom européaniser de l'un
des plus grandes joueuses de l'histoire
mohamed ben issa al khwarizmi qui est
aussi un géant des mathématiques et
surtout le père fondateur de
l'algorithme qui correspond à leur ait
un corps et son algorithme allemand
ainsi la halle goretti lisation de la
loi c'est une solution qui fut trouvée
par les hommes de droit au garantir
l'uniformité risme de la justice pour
différents suspects tout comme
l'algorithme isation des lois de la
nature plus une solution pour formaliser
leur uniforme ni charisme à travers le
temps et l'espace
notre passion de voir l'importance de
l'algorithmique pour le principe
d'uniformité risme c'est de se rendre
compte que dans toutes les suites qu on
a considéré notamment 1 2 4 8 16
les données semblent suivre des règles
comme par exemple la multiplication par
2 or ces règles ce sont en fait des
règles de calcul il règle de pq ce sont
les algorithmes juste pour enfoncer un
peu plus le clou dans l'épisode 28
n'avait vu que les logiciens faire
martin 9 et grégory writing ont postulé
que hazard pouvaient être des
comme l'absence de règles de calcul dit
autrement ce qui permet de rendre les
choses prévisibles
ça semble être l'existence d'un
algorithme qui résument au moins
partiellement les données ainsi en vertu
du principe du ni fort ni charisme il
semble que pour généraliser une suite de
nombres
il faut en fait trouvé un algorithme qui
génère cette suite de nom et c'est sans
doute en appliquant plus ou moins
consciemment ce principe que vous avez
été tenté de compléter la suite 1 2 4 8
par 32 hockey mais comment trouver
l'algorithme qui génère cette suite
et que faire s'il ya plusieurs
algorithmes qui génère ensuite mais si
ces algorithmes effectué des prédictions
différentes pour le prochain élément de
la suite qu'elle algorithmes faut-il
suivre pour identifier les algorithmes
qui explique les données et pour ensuite
prédire le prochain élément de la suite
comment compléter la suite 1 2 4 8 16
même si fuel n'admet la rationalité
d'aucun principe
il reconnaît toutefois que certaines
approches pour généraliser à partir des
données empiriques semble plus correct
que d'autres parmi elles qm insisté sur
l'importance du raisonnement
probabiliste alors la relation entre
filles mais les probabilités est assez
étrange qu il me semble considérer que
l'utilisation des probabilités restent
irrationnel
tout en considérant que certaines
utilisations sont plus correct donc tout
ce que je dis là c'est assez confus a si
souvent on peut avoir une référence plus
clair et plus solide à ce sujet à bâtir
le livre de monsieur fille que dit-il
tout en soutenant qu attribuer des
probabilités à des propositions
empirique restera ultimes moments
irrationnel que me semble par ailleurs
admettre qu'il ya des façons plus ou
moins correct
à défaut de dire rationnelle de
distribuer ces probabilités bon jeu pas
sûr que c'était plus clair
au moins maintenant ça vient d'un
philosophe pour clarifier la vision de
cube il est peut-être utile de remplacer
le mot probabilité par le mot
incertitude après tout ce qui nous
retient de compléter la suite 1 2 4 8 16
partants 200 hésitation ce n'est pas une
probabilité intrinsèque à la suite 1 2 4
8 16
la raison pour laquelle on ne peut pas
être sûr à 100% semble avoir davantage à
voir avec nous
ces études que nous avons sur le fait
que cette suite est la suite des
puissances de 2 pour résoudre le
problème de l'induction
il semble important de répondre à la
question à quel point est-ce que nous
sommes confiants dans le fait que la
suite que je vous ai donné est régi par
la multiplication par 2 quel est notre
créance en une complétion par 32
d'ailleurs même dans le cas du lever du
soleil
il semble persister au moins une très
légère incertitude sur le fait qu'une
suite de 1000 milliards 2 1 doit se
compléter par un an après tout même en
mathématiques il existe des cas où une
suite de 10 puissance 42 données
concordantes
fini par ne plus être concordantes dès
lors ce cas est extrêmement étrange
quand il s'agit d'un duction il semble
ainsi critique de développer un langage
qui repose sur l'incertitude et qui
permet le raisonnement avec
l'incertitude
or il se trouve que le langage du
paysagisme est essentiellement le seul
qui arrivent de manière cohérente comme
l'affirment notamment le merveilleux
théorème de james cox qui mériterait une
vidéo à part entière s'ils connaissaient
les détails de ce langage bayésiens peut
être curieux le qualifierais de correct
pourquoi j'adorerais en débattre avec
lui
quoi qu'il en soit même si multi
et terme anachronique qui me semblent
considérer que l'algorithmique et le
raisonnement avec l'incertitude semble
tout de critiques aux problèmes de
l'induction
et ça c'est en fait sacrément
visionnaire il faudra attendre encore
plusieurs décennies pour qu'un thomas
space hésitant suivi d'un pierre simon
laplace lumineux la place en vienne a
enfin posé les fondements des
mathématiques de l'incertitude
applicable à l'induction
quant à l'algorithmique ce ne sera que
deux siècles plus tard suite aux travaux
d'alan turing notamment que les
mathématiques du calcul furent enfin
poser est comprise et il faudra encore
un demi siècle pour qu'un très grand
génie réussissent enfin à combiner
l'algorithmique et le raisonnement avec
l'incertitude comme vieux me l'avait
envisagé au milieu du xviiie siècle et
ce très grand génie c'est un certain
seuil solomonoff dont on va beaucoup
beaucoup beaucoup parlé dans les
épisodes à venir